Always remember to reverse-gyrate...
...your way out of bathrooms...
...for everyone's safety.
BRRRRUUURHG- IT'SONBITCHES!
BLURGH!
OWMYGOD!
Who's didgeridooing?!
Don't didgeridoo me!
You didgeridoo yourself!
"Oh, not this. Noo!"
[laughing]
I trust you completely!
[imitates machine gun]
[sensual music plays]
"Yhes, oh, Eggs Benedict?"
"Ah, oh, how plebeian of you!"
More like eggs bene-don't!
Heph-heph-heph-heph.
Hurph-hurph-hurph-hurph.
"Oh, monoclemonocle, top hat, monocle."
Are you okay?!
"I don't know!"
What happened?
Oh!
"I can't see anything!"
Horgoth!
Your time has come!
[fear noises]
I'm gonna look over there!
ARRRHGHRARRHG You take those!
Take those eraser, you bitch!
Okay, watch this!
Ready? Ready bro?
Bwoom!
WOAH! OH NO!
"What you do?"
I JUST TURNED MY DIAMONDS INTO PORK CHOPS!
[laughing]
Hello bees, my old friend!
Still not sure if you're... if you're bees or FLIIIIES.
WHO DID THIS TO YOU?!
[bloodpunch]
"Did you do that?!"
No, I didn't do anything! I'm still building Fort Blam Ass.
Hey, shut up, it's not a gay bar!
But even if it was, that would be okay!
So shut up!
Fort Blam Ass.
"That was the dumbest ending to a Hunger Games ever!"
You have 3 arrows sticking out of your body!
"Wade, you have arrows in you!"
I think I won!
[laughing]
"You're covered in arrows Wade."
[more laughs]
Those are old, you only hit me onc--
Oooh.
Oookay.
BLEH, BLEH, BLEH
BLEH
BLEH BLEH BLEH BLEH
BLEH BLEHBLEH
Oh, let's go up to this guy.
[gunshot]
[ding]
Hahahahaha, sweeet.
"Did you kill him?"
[ding]
Okay, let's rob this loser.
See if he's got anything.
Hahahah.
I'm gonna peck the fish outta your butt!
You stupid, freakin' stu--
AAAAH!
Your butt ate me!
What do YOU to become man?!
FIGHT BEAR!
FIGHT MAN!
Bring it on you spider! Yaow.
Oh, I'm shooting pieces of myself!
Where am I going?!
OOOH, I broke it! I broke it!
I broke it! I broke everything!
Whyyy did I break everything?!
Yami's ready to go, let's start this shit.
I thought this was normal--AH!
AH!
Ah!
aH!
You're gonna boil... babies in...?
"I'm gonna boil babies."
I'm gonna boil babies.
BoIl BaBiEs!
bOiL bAbIeS!
BOIL BABIES!!!
"Aaaah!"
Run Wade, run!
Oh, this bad!
Wade, why are we in here?!
"That's the... toilet room!"
AAAAH!
Oooow.
"Is it fair? I have to know."
"Everybody do the flop!" [thud]
...until you make your home country proud!
WAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!
[pure chiptune awesomeness]
[pure anger]
Crep, crep, french, french.
I'm turning French again.
ImdeadimdeadI'MDEADimdeadI'MDEAD!
ImdeadIMDEADIMDEADIMDEAD!
NOOOO!
YEAAAAH!
Get back on there, I need you.
COME ON!
Why am I running like this?
"Hay betch!"
This is the most ridiculous running I've ever done.
What the hell happened?!
AAAAAAH!
[outro music fades in]
Hu-ha-haaawhahahahahha.
You dick!
Ooookay, maybe not... oh! [laughs]
OHGOD, you dick!
Thanks for watching!
All of the videos in this compilation...
...are available in the description...
...so check 'em out!
And if you like to see more in the future...
...please leave a like to let me know.
If you enjoyed this video...
...and you'd like to see more on a daily basis...
...please subscribe today!
Or if you're already subscribed...
...share this video with a friend.
Thanks again for watching!
And I'll see you...
...in the next video!
Buh-bye!
[outro music fades out]